if you've been waiting to play the next
Tomb Raider game I've got great news
it's coming this year I'm Tony and this
is your totally confirmed game spot news
update rumors have been flying for a
while about Lara Croft's next adventure
shadow of the Tomb Raider just this week
people investigated the source code on
the official Tomb Raider website to find
a September 14th 2018 release date on
ps4 Xbox one and PC when the official
countdown on the site ended that launch
was confirmed you'll be able to pick up
shadow of the Tomb Raider this fall
Square Enix released a brief teaser
trailer - saying the game will be quote
Lara Croft's defining moment as she
becomes the Tomb Raider shadow isn't the
only adventure we get this year either
the Tomb Raider live-action movie hits
theaters this weekend and game spots own
Micro Zoo who called it a quote great
video game adaptation and a decent
action movie on its own you can read our
full review of the movie right now or
visit our GameSpot universe channel to
learn everything you need to know before
seeing it
you
[Music]